time to see what you scoundrels have
been up to leave your entry crows I'm
sorry Felix but I can't unseen this this
is the first thing Jack said when I
showed him the figurine you're not the
only one and yes it's 100% intentional
check out PewDiePie that store figurine
out now I'm getting tired of selling you
guys stuff hey I get a lot of cool
opportunities it's like yeah this joker
meme format but it's a jiff Oh God
it's a Jif or gif it's Jeff everyone
knows me making these joker meme into a
jiff gif it will die no also sad oh wait
down bud sorry I'm supposed to sort like
this damn boomer alert the first guy to
criticize China must have been like in
that video that got me banned in in
China oh here I'm saying this I'm
censored one of the haircuts you can
probably guess which one it is and then
literally the me master part I'm certain
it's censored censored censored oh my
god
China is all bad they says our
everything meanwhile can't talk about
controversial topics listen I understand
that there's a difference but at the
same time you and I are not so different
you and I ninja play fortnight with me
Lady gaga I don't even know who you are
bruh that is that was so cringy i
tweeted her shut the Frick up boomer and
everyone's like uh lady guy guys four
years older than you Lady Gaga looks
like my grandma what is for night
googling what are you getting it I don't
understand literally if you google for
tonight four nights still shows up you
dumb [ __ ] subtitles jump-scare
[Laughter]
that's funny me getting my very talented
friend to spend two hours and 32 minutes
for this meme to get 14 up boats people
who screenshot the format and get one
point five thousand up votes why she
draw her so thick though sex is okay but
have you ever lost your house in
Minecraft and then found it again or
your dog no I didn't do anything sexual
with my dog stop complaining
it's your big day happy birthday Marcia
it was a few days ago but yes oh my god
I just realized Dave's facing this Jesus
Lord Jesus Lord Almighty mom did you
fail that test I thought you said your
math was improving it's evolving just
backwards genius oh god what and make a
collab meme I coming together
oh yeah it's a that does not work at all
never try that again if you can produce
a sound louder than 1,100 decibel you
can create a black hole strong enough to
destroy the entire galaxy my dad about
to sneeze are you challenging me I
forget that you guys are actual nine
year old sometimes what what a cute
little kid joking
it's time to go what's a good meme yes
so take this damn it
never give this
how did I do that what huh huh I have
that meme power go away I don't know how
does that work hi I'm the chosen one I
knew it
next name vex me okay now it hurts me
bites onto into burger everything on the
burger opposite end of the burger I am a
head out jaws can we just acknowledge
how Flo Lee designed burgers are can we
talk about this especially as someone
that likes veggie burgers can they just
make one that doesn't flop out like a
mushy smoosh hotdog is the superior
hamburger I'm just gonna say it
legs are detachable so Pierce just had
legs he just never pursued them well
well well you caught me at last it'd be
cool if we could like have see-through
legs so it looks like he can stand on
its own right now you can't do that when
two jokers stares with Murch epically
damn what's the math homework I don't
know ask Joe who's Joe Joe mama who's
Joe why is that funny it's not even
funny if this video gets 1 billion like
then I will be dropping the fattest diss
track on the Chinese government our
freak here we go again
I'll do it power chunko chunko that's
right I probably shouldn't say that
that's a bad idea it's time to go
was IA good meme yes oh no it's already
over for jerker meme so I'm hoping it
would be a month at least when Felix is
peacefully looking at memes and sees
this one oh it doesn't bark anymore meme
review well I would his meme dying
whoa my sister painted this on to my
brother's cast that's sick that's so
cute
well done how
we night rains kids dresses thank you
very
this channel is just me looking at funny
pictures at this point you can't get
uploads from just buying something
person who got the first PDP figurine
observe who's ever got the first one
posted I need to know who it is and
whoever got 69 420 and so on and so
forth I need to know I'll name me an
Ingmar I feel like that's a frickin a
m-- no Ingrid was like a father to me
I just butchered the joke because I
can't read I'm sorry Ingmar you look
like and share it yes okay fine that's
the thing I like this meme but it keeps
no I don't like it marzia Felix wait
repeated Felix yeah I'm gonna do a live
stream mukbang later later next time I
have a pizza follow me on Instagram I'll
be live-streaming and I'll show you
insults how you actually eat a pizza
actually I'll schedule eight thirty
minutes before so you guys have time to
buy a pizza as well and we can eat the
pizza together because I know you guys
are lonely and all that stuff how girls
I think peeing where the penis is like
how it actually is children are included
thanks for specifying thank you for wait
girls think that's what what me and Dad
walking out of principal's office after
getting me suspended never gotten
suspended gamers can't relate actually I
did get suspended once nevermind I
didn't know Google Earth could be better
but I was wrong okay oh god oh my lord
is that dr. Phil epic just a couple
don't zoom on the crotch just a couple
of boomers hanging out that's cool
that's great that's awesome
that's very cool the white guy blinking
me man is raising money for is that what
we're calling it white guy blinking me
man is raising money for an MS charity
Felix perhaps I treated you too harshly
very well white guy blinking me man
you have my support I'm sorry gomen
nasai making tests like going to Mars
NASA has discovered a new planet covered
with marijuana do you guys think
Hustler's calm is a legitimate news
source that I can trust it was an
Internet hoax
Planet X 7 3 7 surprise it was in Planet
X 420 69 but ok when are we gonna see
some aliens like I'm getting sick of
this
come on now sir what is this bunch of
stories about nothing when are we seeing
some [ __ ] Chinese person please
Bart Baker okay that's pretty good but
check this dad
[ __ ] I brought back my old microphone
just after I saw Bart I had to do it
gamers he just sounds like an angel top
hundred most handsome faces of 2019
nominee chi Keanu Reeves
I almost said Kanye West and it's me let
Keanu Reeves be number one let Felix
Kjellberg be number one I'm gonna go
ahead and say it I don't deserve to be
on the list mate have you seen Yuri Yuri
you're [ __ ]
hahahaha L where's Joe WTF who's Joe ah
victory there's no way in hell you win
with your [ __ ] after you just pull a
Joe I mean Joe comes first snoop
d-o-double-g jet let's go you have N
word pass he already used it guys I'm
gonna go ahead and say N word passes
they don't work okay
I've been given many and word passes in
my days they don't do anything
it's push China bans PewDiePie North VPN
hello I like money it's getting it hard
and harder not to salsa for you guys but
yeah I enter code PewDiePie get one
month for free hundred degrees Celsius
Fahrenheit
Kelvin or you wouldn't mention Kelvin in
degrees cringe Kevin it's a unit in
itself
noobs see you're being featured in Lawai
whoever made this has small brain yeah
I'm gonna go and set it whoever made
this one somewhat small peepee I'm just
gonna say it
girls oh my god flying a kite is so
boring boys girls like flying kites or
at least they do now am I right gamers
am i right
oh my god I spent two weeks giving pity
buy his own movie oh wow
my face is so wide oh wow oh it's a
change passion
Thanks next phase very epic a new Disney
would have me back I knew they would
they always come crawling back stop
calling me pity pot stop it stop larry's
well played
fine hey do you like Joe which Joe there
is another that's good I like that me
using a new form eight people who sort
by new the I never understood this red
it mean it's not funny whoever had it
made this small brain and small peepee
two biggest internet legends of 2019 oh
my god it all happened the same year
speaking of Keano if you remember I did
the Keanu Reeves video and I said I was
gonna donate whatever money that video
made it to charity and it actually did
pretty well it made $19,000 which is
really good I think so I guess you guys
actually watch the ads on that video and
yeah I don't hear all that money to
leukemia Research Foundation as promised
I just wanted to let you know that has
happened I would love to do a video on
Joaquin Phoenix as well I think he's
super interesting me and my dad when we
go trick-or-treating with my friends and
their dance that is so cute
I love these names pewdiepie his
submitted the real reason I'm sick of
this meme is suggesting there's not
enough memes about me stop it with this
white man's blinking smiling face me
girls wearing merch up up she's got the
Rolfe as well I like the backpack that's
sick
100 million merch baby sadly I'm not an
a girl even better than the e girl an e
bro you're an e girl in my eyes can you
give Petey pine n-word pants I already
gave him like five times I told you it
doesn't but I'm writing guys
the merchant makes me happy me trying to
press the X button on an mobile ad the
app short accurate it's funny because
it's accurate I love this this this post
has been appearing everywhere it came
from there are teenagers subreddit
someone else I've just taken my son's
phone
I just taken my son's phone how do I
access his history and the first reply
it's impossible okay thanks
so good internet is looking after each
other I love that you just can't it's
it's impossible
god damn why would you take your son's
phone that's up dude beautifies not
abiding china this is how this is his
comment on China China just is just like
that one person in Twitter that can't
take any criticism and just blocks
everyone emails it
I mean it seems like anyone supporting
Hong Kong basically will get banned a
sacrifice worth taking peace was an
option oh my god Dolan freak a dog
question mark Dolan epic PC PewDiePie
there it is oh god am I to boomer to
understand this joke okay I know you
can't polish so when that round ends we
go me dice okay let's go response my dad
okay okay all right I got it it just
wasn't funny
you look like Tobey Maguire you look
like Tom Hollett cool I'll save this for
my meme folder do you want to see the
most illegal thing I own bed plus Stone
equals bedrock
why does Vsauce look like he lived in as
a hermit for 10 years
what happened Vsauce this needs to stop
PD by 2019
dudes shock this meme is still alive
yeah this meme why is it still alive I
want answers now YouTube monetization
light psycho Jane a good guy got gouge a
naked what is that show called they I
think they changed the thumbnail I can't
find it anymore there it is 77 million
views bruh BRR electrons be like
negative No oh is that the new Sonic
that does look better that's cool maybe
there's hope after all
me has barely entered nether ghast
that's my guest impression brah did I
just get cuck goddamn study says that
most vegetarians and vegans eventually
go back to eating meat you could not
live with your failure where did that
bring you back to meet good meme good
meme the best the best part about this
is all the vegans that are posturing and
shaming you for eating meat they're all
very eventually be in the 108 M burger
now like guys I was seriously iron
deficient like you know just shut the up
and eat what you want to eat no one
cares
although beef is bad for the environment
so you should be ashamed of yourself
[Laughter]
slightly moves the mouse my PC in sleep
mode that was me making a startup
computer sound in case that was Nam yes
you guys notice my mouse moves on itself
look what is up with that I'm not I
swore
oh now he doesn't do it anymore Oh what
is up with a cocaine marijuana beer the
first guy did there's something like the
first girl must have been like buttes
remember the way I need to talk about
this I don't do pew news anymore I can't
talk about things
okay so Belle tweeted that she got
arrested right and then she tweeted that
the reason why was because some girl
stole her hamster and she drew this on
her car sixty thousand retweets
this is word-for-word the original
script to John wick like I get it it's
really funny first of all she did not
get arrested second of all this is fake
it's so obvious but whatever oh my god
there yes I want to go through the Joker
stairs so badly
i-it's just my it bothers me it really
does it really bothers me I have a
confession I'm cheating on you oh my god
is it with Joe no with Brad Alex Jake
Kevin and sometimes Jennifer who is Joe
Joe mama five years ago today I asked my
Twitter crush out on a date today I
sir to marry me she said no above times
so here's a Red Hook couple from Google
that's great
well plane Hey so my friend Joe recently
applied for a job at SpaceX you think
you could let him in who's Joe Joe mama
well well you may have roasted me you
have completely forgotten about your
friend Candice who's Candice Candice
dick finally our the opponent god I love
this great school insult
gamers I don't think peers actually have
big brain what hear his epic minecraft
pickaxe slightly bent
I think piers is faking no it's real
every time I'll do big brain it's real
look at the G field it doesn't Bend it
doesn't Bend big brain teen sleeps with
all five of these bullies moms to assert
dominance take this minecraft sword by
the gods you have earned it the hardest
choices require the strongest wails just
pick her wherever you want to freak
that's what I do both how to cook a
vegetable Google Bing that's another
good meanwhile saving this one for meme
folder thank you the first meme to never
die must have been like yeah yeah okay
sure
what's the consensus on the new chapter
in fortnight love it
I miss the black hole the black hole was
so cool it really didn't take long did
it
Oh pores not shutting down a half a day
later its back oh that's a whole lot of
hoopla for nothing vice hundred mil
hoodie my mom throws it away where's my
super suit legit I can't find mine where
is my super suit you know what I'm gonna
order for myself just to show you guys
how easy it is I was supposed to give
one to sign as well alright sigh what
size are you medium how to put a baby to
sleep go go big oh my god that's great
more memes PewDiePie apologizes to
chinese fans chinese fans who can't see
the video yeah i'm a big of a i'm a
[ __ ] i don't know how to tell you guys
i don't know if this should not come as
a surprise to anyone when Felix think
that the fee
we'll die but it comes back a ball stop
hell right alright so I have to say this
do you want to see the most illegal
thing I own pizza but everything is
crust except the crust that is
disgusting I remember saying I don't
like the crust of the pizza and someone
went crust
the crust is the best part you're eating
dough you're eating dough there's no
cheese there's no tomato and you're like
it's the best part you're an idiot
you're fool you're scumbag and you don't
deserve taste buds god damn me slowly
leaves the Wi-Fi coverage area the Wi-Fi
quality Oh God no stop that's how they
go only I can do that
only I can do that from 1940s we bring
you the greatest single sound effect in
the history of comic book wank hey you
want some wank I'll set you up I'll set
you up real good Felix and his minecraft
series at the moment every times caramel
and sea please undersea thank you
Chinese songs exist Bart Baker okay
that's pretty good but check this out
she'll learn fine legitimate Wow I look
like Peter Pan what the hell is this
thing
huh what is that oh my god seeing how
this summer it is flooding with merch I
had it since 2012
that is one of my first merch that's
old-school that's respect
for the first get Pete's old vlog
channel to a hundred thousand so a
random play button appears at his house
I actually follow the password to the
channel I have it now so yeah let's do
it gamers what's the dumbest name we can
make a youtube channel on and get that
to a hundred thousand subscribers or a
million top upload I'll do it I'll do it
for next one to Lane
oh no insanely good artist tagged a
matrix since when did words have genders
almost every European language I am a
head out where's this video where's this
cook from okay
I have a pitch I have a crazy pitch just
use people's names solves all problems
no one has to argue thank you when two
of the smartest kids in class gets
different answers
epic PewDiePie made fun of Chinese
President China banned Peter pie
PewDiePie promotes north VPN China
babies on the plane me this is so
relatable and I'll say it again and I
said it before babies needs to be
shipped in as cargo hahaha even even got
the Holy Bible people showing off their
one piece of merch I'm just like bruh
he's got two shakers that's more than I
had that's illegal
thank you yeah that's awesome when it's
spooked over no one is talking about the
spookiest dog damn that's spooky that's
just spooky dog right there oh you're my
brother in the car crash Brookes six
bones
you got him plushy suspended who live
like that oh we have a speedy recovery
bro it looks like he gave birth to spend
they're not gonna light up when you
double tap in a reddit post please don't
kill me I'm stupid I can't help it wait
eww can double ah Oh enemies school
girls in skirts are so cute is it true
by the way are they actually like you
know what I'm not gonna Google that I'm
a married man
China bench PD partnered VPN allow me to
introduce my tale petition to make hands
count as instrument so a cappella groups
can't climb yeah I like this
alright I think what we need to do I
realize now we have this channel with a
hundred million people right what's of
one thing we can do
it's still possible enough to make it
happen if we get enough people
supporting this idea all right I want to
change the world now I've changed my
mind what I'm thinking it's like it
might be hard to get children banned off
airplanes but something along those
lines something that everyone hates
something that no one likes and it's
just there for no reason we need
changed it we need to make the world a
better place gamers oxygen was
discovered in 1772 1771 be like the
first person to discover oxygen must
have been like
slurps living teacher who broke the
chair ma'am Joe did it teacher who is
Joe me finally my time to shine
finally time to get expelled the three
faces of politicians funny sad angry oh
that's funny a well elaborated smart
youtube comment with a lot of likes and
it oh my god thank you for so much
dumbasses why don't you go and play with
the neighborhood kid the neighbor's kid
it's quite out squirrel
that's my squirtle impressions I'm still
working on it I'm still working on it on
December 31st we should post memes from
2010 to say goodbye to the best decade
of memes yeah let's do that oh oh god I
saw the free hahaha ah thanks I hate it
I already hate it Thomas the Tank Engine
that's that might be something worth
banning adults keep taking away
everything from us video game violence
but why can't we then take away Thomas
the Tank Engine that I can't say using a
2010 format because today's date is 2010
yeah memes were very different back then
I'm not gonna lie it's kind of weird
looking back Hey look he has a name
Droon Scanlon who inspired the viral he
inspired it really is trying to use the
fame to raise money for national
multiple scary scatter a lot scope
society society I'm in when you realize
dead feed applies minecraft series is
almost over push to reset the world I
don't have my safe file so yeah I guess
so worrying about getting banned for
talking about China realizing YouTube is
censored in China Oh No yeah China is a
weird one I posted it on Twitter that
someone else filed for copyright in
China in for PewDiePie a few years
and they sell wedding dresses apparently
as well and my lawyer was like yeah we
can fight it obviously but do you make
any money in China anyway you'll
probably lose anyway because China
doesn't recognize copyright law from
other countries the same way
so now that I'm banned in China haha no
more wedding dresses China you played
yourself fool hello P de Parys I am
woman I just bought clothes PewDiePie
clothes
Wow Wow that's awesome thank you
haha rate Blizzcon 2019 as rid of the
poor they can't ban us all all right
gamers that's it for this week's Lawai
thank you for all the memes of no
support as always I very much appreciate
it check out another video coming right
up and then yeah have a great day see
you tomorrow bye bye well you haven't
tried to pursue me later since me after
50 million outros fetch down just down
it's still relevant just down a bit